but first the latest on our top story
president Trump is using this weekend to
narrow his choices of Supreme Court
picks CBS News has learned there are two
leading contenders the first is Brett
Kavanaugh a 53 year-old circuit court
judge in Washington the other Amy Kony
Barrett a 46 year old who the president
recently appointed to the Seventh
Circuit in Chicago the president left
Washington on Friday to spend the
weekend at his New Jersey Resort aboard
Air Force One mr. Trump said he will
announce his nominee one week from this
Monday he told reporters that he'll be
interviewing several candidates over the
coming days the president also told
reporters he plans to bring up Russia's
interference in the 2016 election when
he meets Vladimir Putin for a summit in
Finland a little more than two weeks
from now some say the meeting holds the
promise for better relations between the
two nations others fear that mr. Trump
may embolden Putin and could drive a
wedge between the US and its European
allies here to discuss the summit is
Kimberly Martin professor of political
science at Barnard College Columbia
University Kimberly good morning good
morning thank you for having me back
thanks for coming back so in this
meeting between the two Trump or Putin
does one of them hold the advantage here
in diplomatic relations no question
Putin does because he's a very clever
man cleverness and trying to get
advantage over your opponent is
something that's really valued in
Russian political culture and I mean
he's been in that position for so long
and he's accomplished so much
internationally whereas we know that
Trump kind of got taken advantage of in
his recent summit in North Korea he
didn't seem to get much out of Kim
jong-un even if he doesn't see it that
way yeah he doesn't see it that way but
really the United States didn't get
North Korea to change much of its
behavior but the u.s. gave up military
exercises with South Korea for right now
the president says he will delve into
Russian meddling it's a topic that has
been off-limits for him for some time
the White House also said so but if
Russia denies it is that just good
enough where do you go from there it's
not clear that the summit itself can
actually accomplish much on that and we
have to remember that Obama had bought
brought up the election meddling with
Putin back in September of 2016 and
no good whatsoever because a month later
what did the Russians do they release
those Podesta emails just at a really
crucial time when Trump had been accused
of or had admitted that he had been
engaged in some behavior that didn't
make him look too savory with women and
the timing of that indicates it was a
Russian ploy and so what Obama had said
a month earlier did nothing to stop
Russians from doing that Kimberly the
president has said he has been no one's
been tougher on Russia than he has his
presidency but I think back to President
Kennedy blockading the Soviets I think
back to Jimmy Carter boycotting the
Olympics Ronald Reagan tear down this
wall
fact-check the President on that has he
been tougher than any other president in
US history and I understand that the
Soviet Union was a different country he
probably hasn't been tougher than all of
the people that you mentioned but I
think if you look at the actual policies
that Washington has put into place
we've got more troops now deployed in
Europe than we had earlier we've
increased our spending on NATO related
military purchases the sanctions have
been very strong against Russia it's not
clear that they're really accomplishing
anything and getting Russia to change
its behavior and it hasn't really come
so much from Trump as an individual a
lot of it has come from pressure that's
coming from the Senate and then from
Trump's own advisors who have not really
been all that pro-russian obviously
Syria will also be on the table in this
summit there's been some discussion that
perhaps the Russia and the u.s. can work
together in at least getting Iranian
troops out of Syria some of that
presence what can be done in regards to
Syria in these two countries well it's
really complicated and there's some
dangers about putting that forward as an
idea because then the question is what
would Putin get in return because Iran
is really a Russian Ally
Russia gets a lot of benefit out of what
Iran is doing in Syria because it means
that Russia doesn't have to be doing
even more and so if Putin says okay
we'll try to ease the Iranians out of
Syria then the question is what does the
US have to give up in response and of
course president Trump has been talking
about wanting to pull all US forces out
of Syria and if that happens our Kurdish
allies that are located in the East
might be left with no support and that
that would not be you know sort of a
good reputational thing going forward
and again as we know this is coming on
the heels this Helsinki visit on the
heels of the NATO summit yes and I mean
a Trump just in the last couple days has
been saying more anti-nato stuff again
talking about people not giving enough
money talking about how you know maybe
we're not sure that NATO is that good it
might be as bad as NAFTA in his words
and so the optics of that could be kind
of bad but again I think you know Senate
support the support of Trump's advisors
I don't think the u.s. is going to
desert NATO anytime soon all right
Kimberly Martin you thank you thank you
for having me here